details die anmuten als stammen sie aus
der vorkriegszeit doch dies ist kein gut
gewartete autoklassiker es ist ein
seifenkisten oldtimer baujahr 2017 und
gehört den beiden schwestern julia und
carlotta haus
wir finden es einfach cool wenn wir
einfach als kinder auch schon ein auto
ich sag jetzt mal ein kleines auto
fahren dürfen und es macht einfach spaß
also ich finde es auch so vor allem weil
diese seifenkiste einen motor besitzt
der zweisitzer der beiden mädchen ist
ein handgemachtes exklusives unikat
erinnert dem englischen vorkriegs
rennwagen lagonda rappi und ist so etwas
wie papas traumwagen
papa ist großer oldtimer-fan er wünscht
sich dass julia und carlotta seine
automobile leidenschaft übernehmen meine
hoffnung ist groß und ich nehme meine
töchter ja auch häufig mit zum
nürburgring auf zur oldtimer einnehmen
auch teilweise an oldtimer rallyes
zusammen mit meiner frau und mir teil
und ich bin zuversichtlich dass das
klappt und dass sie das hobby des vaters
auch zukünftig annehmen werden das ist
der mann der die edel seifenkisten
konstruiert frank banken aus dem
schwäbischen biburg reich wird er mit
seiner manufaktur nicht aber darum geht
es ihm auch nicht sondern um strahlende
kinderaugen
da bin ich so etwas sehe dann das ist
dann bin ich richtig happy weil dafür
sind die autos ja eigentlich gemacht
wenn ich fahre selber auch gern aber
wenn kinder damit fahren wir damit
klarkommen und da richtig spaß haben
sondern es ist somit die größte rolle
damit hat 2012 alles angefangen
indoor von frank banken ihn fand ein
seifenkistenrennen statt
da er seit seinem sechzehnten lebensjahr
an fahrzeugen schraubt baute er sich
kurzerhand dieses renngefährt aus
platzgründen verkaufte er es
anschließend der andrang war groß und so
wurde der seifenkisten bau sein großes
hobby
liebe folgt lautes aller art egal sind
alles keine favoritin ich mag jedes auto
gleich gern von mir
mittlerweile hat sich der außenhandels
vertreter mit den flitzern im oldtimer
look einen namen gemacht
ich habe eine gewisse grund vorstellen
im kopf und dann fange ich einfach
einzubauen und das gibt sich einfach ist
es gibt sich es entwickelt sich einfach
beim bauen es gibt da kein festes
konzept ich weiß wie das auto im
endeffekt ausschauen muss im kopf und
dann schaue ich dass es genau so wird
jede seiner seifenkisten ist ein unikat
die basis ist immer eine holzplatte auf
die einholz gerippe geleimt und
verschraubt wird anschließend fertigt er
je nach fahrzeugtyp die alu karosserie
wochen lang teilweise monatelang schmerz
da die trennung von seinem fahrenden
kunstwerken doch jedes mal jedes mal
aber das problem ist ich kann nicht
alles ich kann nicht alles aufheben
man muss sich dann irgendwann auch mal
davon trennen
ob er wohl bleiben darf frank pankonin
hat diesen echten oldtimer komplett neu
aufgebaut
es gab nur noch das fahrgestell und den
motor des englischen standard aus dem
jahr 1930
auch für christian haas hat er etwas
ganz spezielles gebaut eine seifenkiste
zum rennen üben
die idee war dass ich nicht einen sitz
haben wollte sondern das feeling
wirklich auch hier in der halle spüren
wollte von der wagen es wunderschön
wurde hat natürlich keine räder sondern
läuft auf rollen aber hilft mir sehr für
die rundstrecken rennen zu üben eigene
rennen fahren das liegt für seine
töchter 10 und 11 jahre alt noch in
weiter ferne
im moment geht es darum wann sie welche
der drei seifenkisten steuern
ob die beiden auch wenn sie älter werden
noch wieder papa benzin im blut haben
wird sich zeigen
aber man sieht schon jetzt der apfel
fällt nicht weit vom stamm
[Musik]